hunter tim congratulations you guys have
made it to the final round of this
competition which means that you're both
one step closer to the title forge and
fire champion and that check for ten
thousand dollars
now we're sending you back to your home
for just to recreate an iconic weapon
from history that weapon is
the killer wing
all right
one of malaysia's deadliest traditional
weapons the kellowing is a single-edged
sword used in tribal warfare in the 18th
century this light short sword with its
curved belly and clip tip was a brutal
slasher and stabber
during its brief rule of malaysia the
dutch colonial government deemed the
sword so lethal they banned it from use
before developing their own version to
quell uprisings
with ornate features like an elaborately
carved hilt or an intricate hook on the
spine the kelawang became an elegant
accessory worn at formal events today
its dutch counterpart is still worn at
ceremonies by the royal netherlands army
good luck bladesmiths we'll see you in
five days
my name's hunter johnson i'm from
philippi west virginia my actual day job
i manage a fast food restaurant i've
been placementing part time for about
two and a half years now and i'd love to
be able to do this full time i do not
want to smell another french fry in my
life okay
definitely not the easiest thing i could
have chose to do
but
i think i can pull it off
this hook on the back it's just gonna be
a little bit of structural blacksmithing
but uh i don't like that decorative curl
i got kind of a bad feeling about it
it's very easy if you're just at a bad
angle to ruin the whole thing so you got
to be real delicate real careful and uh
just
make sure you don't screw it up or when
you're this far in
the handle's big in a little weird shape
but it's not hard to make so i think i
can handle that just fine
i'm heating this beeswax
the excess is gonna was gonna soak into
the wood and seal it i know tim's good i
don't know exactly what he's got but uh
i think my weapon's gonna beat his
my name's tim laup i'm definitely a
weapons and armor
nerd possibly bordering on geek
metal is
the medicine for me my wife will tell me
if she'll see me getting danced up about
something and she'll tell me just go to
your shop i'm going to try and get two
blades forged out i want to make sure
that if something does happen i've got
to back up i'm going to put my hot cuts
in and once i get those split
my goal for today is to get both the
blades heat treated doing a differential
deep
since i'm only trying to quench a part
of the blade
it gives me the ability to harden up the
edge and leave my spine much softer that
way it can absorb the shock and not
break
heat treating will make or break my
blades literally
oh for the living
yeah there's a warp the blade itself
entirely is a waste this is why we did
two
wow i'm behind the eight ball on this
one
on the second blade i'll stick with the
normal heat treat
but even then
accidents can pop up and ruin your day
oh she sounds good
it looked to be in pretty good shape
she's hard
my only concern with the hook
is
under extreme duress if you're hitting
something really hard you could end up
snapping that off just from vibration
maybe when it's all said and done i'm
gonna like this
grip and fall in love with it like i did
the blade
i wish she'd balanced just a little bit
further back but she's definitely a ten
thousand dollar weapon
bladesmiths to see what kind of lethal
damage your kelly wang will do i will
take your kelly wang and deliver slashes
and thrust on these ballistics dummy
hunter you're up first you ready
where's i'm gonna get my blade's very
sharp um i cut through probably half a
case of water bottles took no edge
deformation and it's sharp so i just
gotta hope it's good enough for the
dummies while my arm is healed enough to
wheel the knife on the ratchet strap
slash my arm is still healing so
bladesmiths please welcome rj marcaida
he will have the pleasure of wielding
your weapon
[Music]
all right hunters talk about your kelly
one right here
your edge over here is sharp it glides
through and lacerates your weapon went
slashing
broke some ribs your kelly wangser
will kill thank you all right tim you
ready as i'll ever be
all right tim the first thing i noticed
about is your handle the minute you grab
onto it it's all void enough to let us
know and index where the edge is
you have a tip that's also very sharp
and pointed that when it penetrated not
only penetrate it broke some ribs also
here kelly one
will kill
thank you
next up the strength test bladesmiths
we've taken these parts from a buffalo
plow and to test the strength and
durability of your kellowangs i am going
to chop into them
remember this test is all about what
they do to your kellowang and not what
your color wings do to them until you're
up first you ready whereas i'm going to
get
i'm really nervous my sword's lean is
pretty narrow this seems like it's going
to be a lot more brutal on the blades
than what i was expecting
[Music]
well hunter your blade broke the main
issue
was that at the intersection of the
blade and this
decorative curl
there was a saw cut that came in
it's a sharp notch and we call those
stress risers they're a place where
something is going to break the way you
protect against that problem as you
round the bottom of that notch and it
tends to dissipate the energy better
hunter your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure and can no longer
continue with testing however you're not
out of this competition yet
tim your blade has yet to be tested in
our strength test and also must survive
at least five whacks in order for you to
move forward after seeing hunter's blade
snap
i'm worried mine might snap off as well
well tim
it held up can't see any evidence of of
the activity on the edge of this blade
it's still razor sharp
i really enjoyed swinging it nice job
thank you so much
hunter your blade suffered a
catastrophic failure
for that reason i have to dismiss you
from the forge
i'm feeling pretty disappointed i don't
know i just thought it was going to be
more solid than that if i could start
over again i'd make the blade a little
wider a little thicker and make sure i
didn't have a stress point in it well
tim all your hard work paid off you
turned in a keller wing that's deadly
and let's face it looks like a ten
thousand dollar weapon worthy of the
title forged in fire champion
congratulations
i wanted to prove to myself more than
anything that i am at this level it
feels really great to be fortunate fire
champion i can let a lot of those doubts
slip to the side move past them blade
smithing it's not just what i do
is who i am
you